we are going to see and are seeing a
bunch of jobs get automated in a
shock-like way because people need to
find ways at least in the near future to
do things with less human contact
between human beings
and we're seeing this moment that is a
very deep
reminder that people don't have control
over their economic
fortunes that all of a sudden a pandemic
virus
or something a technological advance
could happen in your industry that lays
you off or that destroys the economy in
your town
and so you really get into i think your
argument now for
for ubi um which ai
coronavirus like these things begin to
almost operate as like
metaphors for just a shock and what
happens to people during a shock and do
you want to leave it up to congress to
argue about
expanding ui benefits during a shock so
there's been a lot of movement actually
in the andrew yang direction
or as i often like to think about at the
annie lowry direction
towards just giving people money um
during this uh during this pandemic
and that's been a real policy shift that
is not how we've done things during past
crises so i'd like to hear you talk a
little bit about why you think that's
happened and what you think we can learn
from its performance so far
i am very happy for it to be the annie
lowry direction
[Laughter]
and certainly you know i'm thrilled
about anyone who gets on board doesn't
matter
why or what you call it you know that
there are now dozens of mayors around
the country who are championing
guaranteed income michael tubbs the the
original but there are now dozens of
folks keisha lance bottoms
eric garcetti and around the country who
are committed to universal basic income
pilots
and the reason ezra is that now it's
just common sense where you look around
and you see that there are tens of
millions of americans who have gotten
shoved out of the
labor force because we don't need as
many
bartenders airline attendants security
guards
ushers personal trainers you name it
like there's so many jobs that required
physical proximity that now just don't
make sense and like you said it's not no
one's fault
and so then you look around and say how
are we going to get economic resources
into the hands of
these millions of people and cash relief
is the only sensible solution
and twelve hundred dollars in april uh
going out
had a really positive effect on many
households and on
propping up our economy but we need to
make that regular
recurring predictable we've been
living off of the first cares act
but then now that benefits have elapsed
you're
going to see distress and disintegration
pick up
in many many households and communities
and there really is no feasible
way to help so many households manage
this except for direct cash relief
and it's not just you me and annie and
mayor tubbs at this point
last i i saw 76 percent of americans are
pro cash relief
during the pandemic and 55
are now pro universal basic income so
it's no longer the magical asian man
making this case
it's the majority of americans realize
it's common sense and something we need
to do
so there's a big jump between
using cash transfer for relief which is
what we've seen during the pandemic and
as you say has already
uh republicans already moved into a
chance of opposition on it even though
the pandemic is ongoing
and moving to a basic income floor
and right in the middle of that jump is
this argument that republicans are now
making on the ui on the unemployment
insurance why they won't extend the the
600
which is that if people
can get paid and can support themselves
in their lives without working they
won't work
and the point of american economic
policy should be getting
as many people to work as we can
no matter what no matter what job they
have to take
and so what is your argument to them
what is the argument to the republicans
who say
look relief is fine but we do not want
to be paying people not to work because
we want people working
i would agree and say the last thing you
want to do
is tie economic relief to job status or
employment status
so if you put cash into someone's hands
and say you can have this cash
unless you start working then it
actually is
a detriment to them going back out there
as quickly as possible in some cases i
mean most people will still just be
panicking until they find a job and so
to me this effect is overstated and
overblown
but to the extent it exists you are
right now tying a lot of this cash to
employment status i would say make the
cash unconditional
and then you'll have a baseline and if
you go out and get that part-time job
because it's not ready for to be a
full-time job because
the bowling alley or the retail store is
not at full
reopening yet then you get to keep that
money as opposed to right now
saying well wait a minute if i take this
job then i stop getting benefits
so the problem right now is our existing
legacy
infrastructure that ties the cash relief
to
not working do you think the us
government has a
spending constraint on it could could we
do a ubi
and agree new deal and medicare for all
and just put it on the put it on the
national credit card or
do we have limited resources and we have
to make choices between them
well the argument i made on the trail
ezra which i sense you'd agree with
is that we have a revenue problem in
that the biggest winners
in the 21st century economy are paying
zero or near zero in taxes very often
and the most prominent example is amazon
the trillion dollar
company that paid zero in federal taxes
last year and so what i said to folks is
like look
if you have amazon paying zero taxes
you're gonna have affordability problems
for sure
and that if you harness the gains from
the amazons and apples
and netflixes of the world then
you have a lot more revenue to work with
very quickly and then if you put that
money into people's hands that money
does not disappear it ends up going
right back into the
local economy in the form of car repairs
and daycare expenses
and the occasional meal out
and those businesses all then create
more opportunities
and can create virtuous cycles uh
that help end up creating jobs
and human well-being but the big thing
ezra i think is that we need to stop
measuring
our economy in terms of these narrow
economic outputs
where if you try to figure out what's
good for us by what's good for the stock
market then you're lost
and so if we wait but but i'm going to
hold you on i'm going to hold you on
this argument before you go into it
because i want to stay on the
i'm not measuring our economy by now
economic outputs by gdp right here i'm
the the question i'm asking is um is can
we afford it i think we need to
pay for yeah do we need to pay for
things like this and what i would say is
i know
the the corporate tax data on this stuff
you know well enough to say
that the list of things i just gave you
medicare for all ubi
and green new deal you could do
everything that
the folks i know who want to tax
corporations and rich people quite a bit
more
think we should do and in most cases i
want to do those things too and you
wouldn't come near
paying for this set of things so at some
point you have to there is a question of
whether or not these things are worth
raising taxes for which i often think
they are
but taxes are a hard sell and then
there's a question which
you will sometimes hear people associate
with modern monetary theory and other
things
arguing which is it maybe we don't need
to raise taxes for them now a lot of
mmters would say
you can't do things this big without
raising taxes because you'll get
inflation so that's a that's an argument
as well
um but but that's my question for you
like do we need to figure out how to pay
for it because we have to figure out how
to pay for it
then it's going to be a um it's going to
force more choices and more sequencing
i agree with everything you just said
ezra and i also have seen the math
i know the price tags on some of the
things we're talking about
but one of the things i said to folks on
the trail
was what is the cost of not addressing
climate change or what would the cost of
climate change be if we just let it
wreak havoc and ravage our country and
then people reflect on that for a second
most of them don't know you know the
size of the economy pre-pandemic was 22
trillion or so so if i throw that in
there then they say well
climate change is going to cost us
trillions of dollars and thousands of
human lives if we were to do nothing
and so then you start thinking okay the
cost of inaction
is in the trillions so then
what is the benefit of our investing
in climate change mitigation
particularly if you start
measuring how we're doing based upon how
we are actually doing as human beings
like if you have
a group of people drinking unclean water
or
having their town submerged you know
that that might not show up in
certain economic indicators but it ought
to
so the the way i'd answer your question
is to say that
uh we should not be thinking we can just
do everything under the sun
uh in terms of putting it on the
government's
bottom line but we can be much much more
aggressive than we currently are
about making large-scale investments in
our own future in our infrastructure
addressing climate change and putting
universal basic income into our hands
because in many cases a lot of these
investments will end up
paying us back in both human ways and
economic ways
and the the argument i make on the trail
was that if you have universal basic
income in people's hands
does that improve our educational
outcomes does that improve our health
outcomes
does that reduce the cost of
incarceration
does that improve the ability of
ex-convicts
their ability to reintegrate into
society like there are many many
things that we spend a ton of money on
right now that we could
reallocate or alleviate if we invested
directly in our people
and that's what a lot of people were
missing oftentimes is that
the investments you and i are describing
actually pay off and in many cases pay
for themselves
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you